okay thank you everyone I'm Cole
Harrison with Massachusetts piece action
I want to welcome you to our afternoon
session we are talking this after could
everyone please be silent we are talking
this afternoon about how to mobilize to
reduce the dangers of nuclear war peace
action is a sixty-year-old organization
we were formed to ban the bomb in the
50s as the committee for saying nuclear
policy we're now peace action we
continue our work for nuclear
disarmament as well as against us wars
and occupation and to move the military
budget to meet the needs of our people
we have three great panelists today with
different aspects of mobilizing and I'm
going to introduce each one before their
remarks Jonathan king who was the
initiator behind the program chair for
today's conference and the initiator
he's professor of molecular biology at
MIT the author of over 250 scientific
papers and a specialist in protein
folding he was a leader in the
mobilization of biomedical scientists to
renounce the military use of
biotechnology and to strengthen the
biological weapons convention he was a
founder of the jobs with peace campaign
in the 1980s and he is now chair of the
nuclear disarmament working group of
Massachusetts peace action he is also an
officer of the Cambridge residents
alliance and of the citizens for public
schools Jonathan King thank you cold
thank you thank you can you hear me is
this working III got ya okay so up there
on the in front of you probably the
clearest expression of our national
priorities is the distribution of
spending in the annual congressional
budget so this is the money that
Congress votes on each each year to run
the country the pie chart is produced by
the national priorities project out in
western Massachusetts and shows how this
money was allocated in 2015 as you see
the single largest category is Pentagon
spending more than half of all the money
the government spent that year and the
year before that year before that and
the current here and these expenditures
are larger than all other federal
civilian programs put together
transportation food and agriculture
basic scientific research housing it and
community it's not only that those are
those portions of the budget haven't
grown its they've been actively shrunk
over the last decade and among the
components of and shrunk are the ones
that take care of the most vulnerable
members of our population cuts in the
WIC program for food assistance for
women's infants and children training
and placement the unemployed funds for
affordable housing title one grants to
disadvantaged schools Pell grants for
low-income students all the things that
people really need have been cut and the
damage this is real damage that it's
done to tens of millions of people this
is just regretting it not everybody is
comfortable looking at pipe our charts
so there's a bar chart on the left the
military and on the right other things
look at the one next to the right
because I'm going to come back to that
that's public transportation now the
major component of all this money is
individual income taxes how many of your
friends and neighbors know that half of
their income taxes go every year
more than half to the Pentagon how many
of you know that half of your income
taxes go every year that very very few
people know that right it's taken out is
withholding city of Cambridge does a
great job sending out a brochure every
year explains how the property taxes are
being spent nobody tells you how your
income tax is being spent now that's one
thing that's obscured the other thing
that's obscured is the actual split in
this budget in November in December this
budget was moving slowly through
Congress because the Republicans even
they could even though he's a backwards
budget couldn't agree on passing it New
York Times at 10 or 15 articles front
page articles about whether the budget
was going to be passed or not boston
globe at a dozen articles not a single
one of those articles mentioned that of
all that money more than half was going
to the Pentagon know what did they ever
mention that it was your income taxes
many of my neighbors believe that the
Pentagon budget comes from out there
somewhere right right they were and they
wouldn't believe it if I said no it
comes from it comes from you right so
that's part of the kind of right-wing
conspiracy r
is to make sure you don't know uh you
know these essential aspects of it now
the the cuts cause social mobilization
the cutbacks in public housing all
across the country people are in
distress because they can't stay in the
houses they can't get section 8 vouchers
or my colleagues whose by all those
research programs really good research
programs are being cut that graduate
students can't continue during research
can't get jobs there in the state and um
people who have to get to work or get to
school get to the hospital by on public
transit I've been very upset now though
I need not point out to you the
Republicans are very very good at saying
there are against big government they're
against big government when it's for
anything we need when it comes to
nuclear weapons they are all for big
government giant programs f-35 upgrade
the the Trident submarines etc so that
thing being against big government is
very so very selective the last myth
that's promulgated and this we run into
continuously often with our friends is
the notion that those two parts of the
budget are separate pots right the
military budget is separate from the
political budget that is false there's a
single federal budget and in any year
the Congress can vote to cut the housing
and put the money for Trident submarines
or they could vote to cut the Trident
submarines which would free up money for
frowsy so don't let anybody tell you
congressman capuano puts that out all
the time oh we have a separate budget we
can't we can't move back and forth you
know move back and forth you cut one and
put the money freed up the other so
that's important thing to keep in mind
now in peace action has been around for
quite a while a lot of experience trying
to talk about nuclear weapons and in in
recent years we've become part of
something called the budget for all
campaign which talks about the state
budget dependence on the fit under
federal budget and that coalition has in
many groups that have many many members
the massachusetts association of HUD
tenants service employee unions teachers
social service groups without thousands
of people who depend on the budget one
of the things we discovered for example
there were lots and lots of people
waiting at t stations when the snow
stopped the tea running they just
standing around right but if you went up
to them and say you know we have this
terrible situation with the proposed
trillion dollar modernization of our
nuclear weapons and it's going to
decrease our national security it just
didn't quite get their attention but if
you went up to them and say you know we
could solve this problem we could buy
100 no red line cars you could open the
conversation and then you get back well
but that would cause millions of dollar
cost millions of dollars then you can
say well look you know we're spending
billions on the nuclear submarines how
about we just build Subway's rather than
submarines so our budget for all
campaign developed a kind of outreach to
the stranded transit riders which we
call subways not submarines or build
passenger trains not nuclear submarines
and there's a flyer that was given out
at stations which uses this people's
budget as the way of talking about the
budget now I don't have to remind you
you've heard and you'll hear more later
on how expensive these nuclear
submarines are right we already have 14
if one of them fires off the missiles
obliterates the major cities of any
country on earth we don't need 14 of
them meanwhile the government is
proposing to build eight more 100
billion dollars enormously expensive the
congressional budget office estimated of
estimate 348 billion over the next 10
years to upgrade the nuclear for the
nuclear modernization we're not talking
here but we will it next year
conference that one of the key drivers
is not fear of the Soviets it's that
enormous profits are made on these
contracts their monopoly contracts
because you can't outsource through the
Chinese their cost plus company gets
paid against a profit no matter how
inefficiently they manufacture missiles
and there's no auditing you can't
examine what's going on because secrecy
because national security puts a blanket
that prevents audit so there's no oddity
now what we're talking about is very
realistic a Boston sent last year to the
Pentagon in income taxes Boston
residents about a billion dollars it's a
thousand million if you just cut cut
that twenty-five percent and put forty
percent of that money into transit
masters's would get back enough to buy
50 new red line cars so this is very
very cut concrete cut back build a few
less submarines we can get 100 new red
line cars now I want to close with the
form we're taking this effort which is
the people's budget campaign buying
these weapons it's an aggression alors
ation appropriation House of
Representatives this little is the lead
right that's the political target cut
the budget not the Pentagon citizens
have no control over the Pentagon but
our elected representatives have some
control over there is already in the
Congress in the house of representatives
of progressive caucus 75 members and the
Progressive Caucus writes an alternative
budget which is now called the people's
budget and the people's budget does
actually cut some military spending and
given the letters they're all going to
get from you next year right they're
going to cut a little more maybe they'll
cut the nuclear modernization freeing up
much more money on the on the pull on
the human side so that allows us to work
together with the Coalition for basic
human needs the National Alliance a
hotel
American Federation of Teachers because
we say we can say to them you want more
money for health education welfare join
us and cutting the the nuclear weapons a
budget we don't have it now we used to
have years ago but we needed to have it
again leaflets that make very clear to
people that it's their tax dollars and
where the attack so let's go and very
clear what the trade-off is you want
houses what do you want more Trident
missiles and make that very clear too
that's a campaign that's begun strange
as it may seem the peace movement is
playing a key national role because all
the other groups had historically fought
against each other the housing people
don't care about biomedical also don't
care about biomedical research but they
don't they end up competing against each
other now in the people's budget they
come together and we say join us and
cutting the military side you can get
what you need so looking forward to
working with you together in the future
thank you for being here